moving to Washington Congress is set to
extend a federal aid program for
struggling businesses after criticism
that too much of the money has gone to
large corporations last night President
Trump called on Harvard University to
return more than eight million dollars
in emergency aid Harvard which had a
forty 1 billion dollar endowment before
the recent stock market downturn says
100 percent of that grant money will go
to support students Lygia jiang is at
the White House for us with the latest
on that plus mr. Trump's newest plan to
restrict immigration we should good
morning what do we know about that plan
Tony the president just tweeted this
morning that he will sign an order today
to suspend the issuing of green cards
for at least 60 days in order to cut
that competition for American jobs as
the economy rebounds although some
people like seasonal agriculture workers
will be exempt critics say this is
merely a political stunt President Trump
is set to sign executive action that
will temporarily suspend applications
for permanent residency claiming the
move will help Americans looking for
work by pausing immigration will help
put unemployed Americans first in line
for jobs as America reopens and
Democrats have accused mr. Trump of
having an ulterior motive fulfilling a
campaign promise to scale back on legal
immigration meanwhile there was some
good news for the more than 22 million
unemployed Americans congressional
leaders finally came to an agreement on
adding additional funds to the Paycheck
protection program or PPP sure always a
lot of claims about who won and who lost
but I think the American people are the
ones who won the nearly five hundred
billion dollar deal includes 310 billion
dollars for small business loans 60
billion of which will be set aside for
smaller banks and lenders when the first
round of aid was distributed large
entities received 10 million dollar
loans Shake Shack returned its money and
the administration wants others like
Harvard University to do the same
Harvard is gonna pay back the money
and they shouldn't be taking it Harvard
pushed back late last night saying the
money they received came from a
different fund meant to help struggling
students the deal also includes seventy
five billion dollars for hospitals and
25 billion for virus testing it's
unclear exactly what a national testing
program will look like with the House is
expected to pass the bill tomorrow and
the president has already indicated he
will sign it meanwhile the White House
is already eyeing a brand new phase for
stimulus package hoping to revive the
ravaged economy Gail
a lot of people today we should sing
show me the money thank you very much